bonjour thot
hier marié avec steven pas d'enfant
également c'est prévu ou par non à des
animaux ça nous suffit alors la
comparaison et l'a23 différence mais le
passage à niveau sont plus propres oui
et puis des eaux de
[Musique]
maria ici là bas
c'est sûr
non mais non mais non c'est pas
une chambre tu vois là jean marc ela
contre c'est quoi ces s'encordant vous
fait pas de film un jeu très grand
c'est pas ça se voit mais choisit atik
sais pas trop je pense mais on avait pu
t pour avoir un petit membre bon moi que
je connaissais même pas à moi ah bon
c'est votre réputation apparemment c'est
pas apparemment mais en tout cas jusqu'à
moi cette ce cliché ouais ben je voulais
après je vous l'apprends aujourd'hui le
13h de france 2 devient de plus en plus
étrange ouais c'est très chaud et un
tabouret quand gaston voulez l'essayer
ah oui bien sûr il faut bien poser la
rondelle
fondu d'un tiers
sur le petit noeud on nous met trop
sympathique appel chantilly
bas on tire sur le noeud on installe
bien la rondelle et on rajoute de
l'achat elle est fan de donald trump et
elle a été très précise mais très
précise de quilles et joe biden
c'est une femme qui m'a énormément fait
rire j'ai beaucoup suivi pendant le
tournage d'un documentaire avec agnès
vincent qui était la patronne des
opérations spéciales à ce moment là sur
le service public et bernadette massé
mourir de rire et compris une fois quand
elle m'a montré comment on faisait une
sas ya sur le sol et y remettre la tête
entre les gens pour faire et à l'été
mais vraiment à mourir
oui oui j'ai fait tout mon coeur
[Musique]
malgré leur réputation de glaçons
émotionnel les hommes n'aurait en
réalité aucun problème à dire je t'aime
en premier alors partenaire études
internationales 1500 personnes
interrogées en france en australie au
brésil en colombie au chili et oui la
conclusion c'est que les hommes disent
souvent je t'aime en premier à leurs
partenaires même si les chercheurs
parlent d'un biais d' aveux masculin cet
ami a rencontré les médias au travail
elle nous dit clairement et à plusieurs
reprises de nombreuses fois niet ben ils
continuent à la harcelait mais des
dizaines et des dizaines de messages
enflammés tous puis dit et on dit que
les uns que les autres ça va jusqu'au
point où ils déboulent lui ppda tousart
du 20 heures qu'il est en bas de chez
elle à la porte en train de hurler à
l'amour et comme on dire elle doit
demander à son mari de descendre pour le
chasser en fait ce premier jeu de même
ne serait pas toujours désintéressés
parce que souvent ils seraient dans le
but d'accélérer des rapports sexuels
voilà ce que nous disent les chercheurs
il y aurait un je t'aime un peu
intéressés de la part des hommes c'est
la course que je fais des hypocrites
voilà ce que vous êtes je voulais offrir
un petit parfum napoléon 1er parce que
c'est gentil lagarde va te dis que ce
sont des bobos
[Applaudissements]
leur magnifique cadeau j'ai un truc à te
dire c'est le mensonge des bons à rien
puisqu'il ne trompe qu'une fois visé
cannabis à
une phrase qui va parfaitement aux
mythomane que tu es